people absolutely hate Congress how
should they hate them they have like a
negative 642 approval rating which is
almost impossible but it turns out that
a new study is proving that women the
women in Congress are getting a lot more
done than the men surprise surprise
let's look at some info quorum which is
a startup that analyzes congressional
relationships and policymaking found
that over the past seven years female
legislators have been more likely to
work with the female members of the
opposite party and more likely to see
their bills passed compared to their
male counterparts I'm not surprised a
little more for you okay so these are
average bills co-sponsored with each
senator of the same gender so male
senators on average got about four of
these bills out female senators got six
all right a little bit more also keeping
in mind that there are way less women in
the Senate than there are men men
introduced on average about 70 bills
women introduced 96 that's a pretty
significant difference men got an
average about three bills out of
committee so that means it went the next
step to becoming law or at least getting
to the President's desk women got almost
five and men got on average about one
and a half bills enacted and women got
2.3 so by every estimation if you just
look at the empirical evidence women are
getting more done in Congress you know
there's a causality thing I think is
what you're gonna first tell me here
right no no you're not going to tell me
I'm you know and whenever I see a study
like this i have like questions about
standard deviation and sample size i'm
wondering if mrs. maybe that there's so
much fewer female congressional
representatives yes you know that the
experiment doesn't make sense based on
that right so okay so we can't totally
break down all the science of it but
there's a general theme here that women
seem for one reason or another to be
getting more done right I think it's an
interesting hypothesis and I don't know
for some reason this study did raise
some red flags for me but even if
everything in that study is true I still
don't think the results from the women
are that impressive right which were
kind of speaks to how low our standards
are for Congress right and the reason
why there's a lack of bipartisanship
isn't because people are inherently bad
in there unwilling to work with one
another it's because they have corporate
interests at play they have people
funding their campaigns and so even if
they genuinely feel strongly about it an
issue they're not gonna be principled
about it because they gotta think about
reelection and funding their campaigns
right so I get that I'm totally on board
yet everyone is bought and sold and
that's why Congress doesn't get anything
done and all that's up but you guys
think that maybe there is something
about the female mind just because men
and women have different thought
processes right uh that maybe is
allowing them despite all the corporate
interests to still maybe get some more
done like that I mean that's just what
the numbers are saying there are some
stereotypes that women are more
empathetic than men so that could
probably factor into them being willing
to cross party lines and work with
others yeah um so yeah I mean there are
things about men and women that are
inherently different there's no question
about that uh whether or not those
differences play a role in the study i
think is yet to be proven so I'd like to
see more you know research into this and
we'll figure it out but I think you
start getting into dangerous territory
when you say women in Congress are
better than men in Congress or you know
men in Congress are better than men
women in Congress I just think that
right now we don't know what any of
those bills were so we may be against
all of the bills that the women were for
probably not but you really have no idea
are you guys more inclined to vote for
women in general if you see if
everything else is equal would you be
more inclined to vote for a woman if you
didn't particularly care about either
candidate either way everything is equal
cuz i will start there everything was
equal which pretty much never have i've
never seen that happen once yeah so am i
just more likely to choose a woman over
a man if you didn't particularly have a
dog in the fight then I'm not voting
then you wouldn't vote yeah interesting
well yeah that's actually a really good
point if you have two candidates that
are basically the same why vote you're
gonna get the same result um but no I
don't think that I'm more inclined to
vote for a woman as opposed to a man I
think that it really just boils down to
the issues but if let's say all the
candidates are exactly say but the only
thing I'm voting on is a man versus a
woman I think right now considering how
underrepresented women are in Congress
sure I guess I'd vote for the woman
right so in and of itself you're not
necessarily vote for Hillary oh no no
I'm actually little too corporate little
too it's definitely 100 not stooping
you're not right but I'm guessing you
both might vote for Elizabeth Warren but
you would say that sounds of policy
absolutely not because it's always
policy that has to be number one you
can't just be like I only want a women
in Congress cuz you don't what Sarah
Palin's a woman and she was crazy Sarah
Palin's a woman do you agree let's